[Music]
all right let's go to
uh let's see nicole in kansas city
what's up nicole
hi dr john how are you doing just
started listening i just started
listening to your book this weekend
it's amazing it's awesome you think so
really that makes me happy yes hey and
it's making me happy when it's right
when this call is over if you will just
uh dm me your venmo and i'll send you
some cash for saying that i'm really
great oh my gosh that's so nice you
don't need to do that but i appreciate
it i don't even know how the no works i
really can't do that but i'd sound it
cool
so hey what's up how can i help all
right so i am i'm a divorced mom of two
awesome kids um my nine-year-old
daughter
has been diagnosed with with adhd
she's also been diagnosed with
oppositional defiant disorder which i i
know is controversial but the fact is
that she actively
defies me if the default answer is no on
everything um and she
rejects anything that's important to me
you know uh so you know if if it's
something that i i like or i want to do
it's going to be a no automatically um
give me an example
um
so you know even just like let's go to
the zoo today
no i don't want to go to the zoo today
i mean it's just everything is a default
no but my question that brings me to my
question so i am um in a relationship
now you know i'm dating someone um and
well i shouldn't say dating i'm in a
relationship and we've been together for
some time now um you all need to have
the dtr you need to define this
relationship yeah well it is defined
we're in a relationship and
you know i introduced my kids um early
on in the relationship i introduced my
kids to
this
man and um they
you know i didn't introduce him as a
boyfriend right away you know just we
just kind of hung out in a park a couple
times
and uh you know went to like steak and
shake um but
you know at the time my very very
jealous ex-husband freaked out um and so
it sort of set me into a spiral of you
know this is too early i should be doing
this you know and um then covet came and
the truth is
you know it's been about 18 months now
i'm still in this relationship
and um my my daughter i've now now told
her that i have a boyfriend and she is
angry you know and she um
tells me all the time it's now becoming
like a part of
what she
brings up when she's um upset
so you know if i make her mad in some
way if i give if i place a boundary or
use some some discipline you know that
the line is you know i hate i hate you
you shouldn't be with this boyfriend you
know um you know i i don't like you i
don't like him and you know i i don't
ever want to be around him
and it's really holding me back from
i feel like i'm living two lives in a
lot of ways where i have this
life where i'm in a relationship and
it's very good and it's very solid and
then i have a separate life when i'm
with my kids
and um i'm feeling really stuck and so i
would love some advice on how to
move forward yeah you got it man thank
you so much for
so clearly laying this all out that's
really helpful
um all right so i'm gonna you
we could have had we could have a whole
show just pulling this one call apart
okay yeah you got several things here
um so i'm gonna throw a lot at you you
stop me if you want me to to dig into
things okay and i was just feverishly
taking notes while you were talking here
um
okay so i wanna back out to odd yeah you
know me and adhd okay
um
the
the
most compelling argument i've read both
physiologically and psychologically is
that
those two disorders if you will if you
want to call them that
are a
combination of of you know uh genetics
and combination of experience whatever
it's a body's response to chaos okay
yeah so you see that a lot in divorced
families
if kids because there was something
leading up to the divorce too right i
mean there was a season leading up to
yes and so that's that's the thing it's
like she's been this has been her way of
being her whole life you know long
before the divorce right right so i hear
that i hear that so here
i don't want you to
go in the mirror and be like i ruined my
kid and all that's not gonna help
anybody okay
it's just saying okay i'm i'm gonna let
adhd and odd and whatever other labels
somebody wants to throw at your kid
that's fine
that's a context not an excuse for how
we're gonna treat one another how we're
going to live in this house how we're
gonna do life together okay
and so um the way i explain it to my son
as and i'm a guy who's my adhd is
comical it's it's off the charts it's
ridiculous
um so what does that mean that means i
have to set up systems so that
it doesn't give me a pass on showing up
to work on time on treating people with
respect on being kind being prepared i
don't get a pass on that i just have to
do more work than the average person to
get ready for some stuff i got to set
alarms when i sit down and talk to my
kids in the morning so that i don't miss
um like when i need to leave so that i
can be on time for my recording right or
to be on air whatever the thing is and
so i just have to create a new life and
that's fine everyone's got their stuff
but often when we have young kids
especially kids of divorce that are
really acting out hard or they're really
struggling with focus and attention or
they just sit in the back of a room and
they disappear
we we tend to lean into they've already
had enough they've been through enough
like let's just let this thing pass or
this past
and here's what a kid is screaming for a
couple of things number one one of the
most common child fantasies is that my
mom and dad are gonna get back together
if i can just get them to see me in the
right way
some kids double down on making straight
a's they become the perfect kid they're
trying to they think they were the
problem
other kids say can you see me can you
see me can you see me and that looks
like i'm screaming i'm yelling i'm
banging my head against the wall
ultimately there's this fantasy of where
we're getting back together if it was
possible which it might not be
i would love
a conversation now that your daughter's
nine with you and your ex-husband and
her
to say we still respect each other
um i'm dating somebody is your husband
is your ex dating somebody
yeah okay we are we still respect each
other you're still our baby girl you're
still the number one in our lives
when it comes to our kid i mean you're
still so
important let her know there's there's a
period in of y'all's relationship
sentence right we're moving on here that
may not be possible not all ex are that
mature and that grown up but that would
be a gift to your child it'll hurt and
it'll be a mess and it will cause
kicking and screaming whatever but it
will allow her to begin to toggle out of
if i just do something they'll get back
together
and that leads me to
you mom are giving way
too much power to this nine-year-old
yeah that's what my therapist says
listen
here's it's not only when i say you're
giving her too much power you are but
that's not about you
she can't handle the weight of what
she's trying to carry around because
she's not yeah
and she's heartbroken and she's her
brain is firing all over the place right
she's got some she's got some true
neurological struggles right now or
psychological struggles or both and so i
would begin to in short order really
reclaim the ownership of your home
what does that look like when your child
says um i wrote this down here um i hate
you
number one she doesn't she doesn't have
words for i'm i my body reacts when you
come in the room because i feel like i
screwed something up like i broke up my
family like i'm none and they didn't
love me enough to stay together all
those things are overwhelming her nine
year little brain
and it comes out i hate you that's the
only language she has
a response to that is i'm so grateful
that you
felt brave enough to share that with me
we don't use the word hate in this home
but you are welcome to not like me right
now and i and you're allowed to do that
so thank you for sharing that
and here's what she's finding
she is not responsible for mom's
emotional regulation
and if she can get you off kilter then
she has the power in your home and if
you flip that on its head she feels
responsible for how mom is doing
how mom feels and she cannot carry that
weight it's too much yeah
and so taking the sting out of i hate
you you just know this just hear me say
it she doesn't hate you she loves you
she just doesn't know what's happening
in her body
so cool and does she weaponize it does
she all over dad like he's the best he's
the greatest the whatever yes oh yeah
yeah she loves dad she loves dad's new
girlfriend oh the best she's awesome she
talks about the new girlfriend all the
time you know and then it's like she
hates
hates me hates my boyfriend right now
you are not living your life for the
approval of a nine-year-old
oof yeah okay
you are using your wisdom and your
strength and your grief
to parent this young child through a
really tough situation
um
some kids won't talk um i've continued
to get uh messages back that are really
um they fill me up they're awesome of
parents whose kids wouldn't talk to them
either they were annoying or they were
like shut up mom i don't talk to you
whatever and they started doing the the
journal on the bed
i write a note to my kid and then they
write me back
and the feedback i'm getting is it's
phenomenal like it's such a comically
easy tool that parents didn't know about
kids won't say things sometimes but
they'll write them down and it may be i
hate you i hate you i hate you you're an
idiot i hate your boyfriend
the response is thank you so much for
sharing that with me he's a really great
guy and i look forward to the day that
you feel safe around him
and leaving it at that and it's gonna
slowly take the sting out of that stuff
and she's going to realize this isn't
working and mom still loves me
and
i can't punish my mom because my mom's a
grown up and it's not allowing me a
nine-year-old to punish her right
um and you just you know this it's just
gonna be a
y'all have a road to ho man you're going
to have a young daughter that's going to
be constantly asking herself what she
did wrong and it's going to take some
really wise parenting co-parenting on
you and your ex
to let her know she didn't do anything
wrong she's a lovely wonderful young
girl
um yeah and then man at some point you
got to bring your if that's this guy's
going to be part of your life going
forward your daughter feels that gap she
feels that there's two moms too
yeah a mom that's getting dressed to go
out who's excited to let the that let
the
burden of this whiny nine-year-old in
this chaos of a house go so i can just
go out to eat and be with another
grown-up who actually likes me and she
feels that and so there's there's got to
be some sort of hey he's gonna come you
are welcome to join us for dinner you
don't have to say anything
and after dinner then you can go film
watch something or whatever go play some
games or whatever um but i'm gonna set
the boundaries here and here's one quick
trick with some a kid who struggles with
oppositional divine disorder
um it's just funny i may have talked
about this on the show or not
my wife was talking with a we're at a
parent-teacher conference and my son
doesn't have that but we were talking
about discipline and
i think it's called conscious discipline
if i mean it's it's a it's an
educational technique
okay but they were discussing it with
each other so it was my wife who's the
scholar and was sitting down with a
teacher and they were talking about um
how they do discipline
and
i i i was listening to explain it back
and forth and finally i stopped and i
looked at my wife and said you do this
to me
and she smiled real big and it's like
yeah i do
so here's here it is
it is giving this child a framed sense
of ownership
so when instead of saying hey we're
going to the zoo today is that going to
be great then no
you suck i hate you we're not going to
the zoo zoo's the worst
um
it is here's three options
and one of the options can be ridiculous
we can sit outside in the yard and do
nothing that can be one of them
or we can go to a movie or we can go to
the zoo
you get to pick i'll give you 15 minutes
and i'll put on your favorite music
while you decide
and then there's this sense of
that's what i'm talking about i'll tell
you what we're going to do today right
and there's a a and a sense of ownership
and really you framed the whole thing up
yeah that makes sense although it does
lose my other child in the mix but i
mean that's a whole another conversation
or yeah or this time you get to pick
next time um you're the other chagas to
pick or you all get to work on this
together and if you all don't come up
with something in 15 minutes i'm picking
and i'm gonna pick that we're just gonna
go eat broccoli at a local restaurant
right i'm gonna pick something
ridiculous but we're gonna let that
nine-year-old choose let those kids own
it and then you win because what you
want is great fun time with your kids
and you'll get that and they will go
with their head heads held high and
their chest puffed out a little bit
there may be some you can't make i'm not
doing any of this stuff you can't make
me do any of it and then you can say
yeah we are you're coming with us
because you're nine and i'm just bigger
than you right and you don't ever want
to resort to that sort of power but
um sometimes you have to with
she's always nine-year-olds but here's
what we're having we're just gonna take
that that weight off of your kid she's
not running the show anymore and maybe
you even sit down with your
nine-year-old depending on how
articulate how much she can understand
take her out to breakfast and say
it's been a hard few years and you've
had to own a lot of what's going on in
here
so i'm going to start
i'm going to take ownership back of the
house you're my little girl and you have
a special place in my house this house
doesn't work without you i love you so
much
and so i'm gonna start picking up some
of the slack that i've let you have and
here's a couple of the rules we're not
gonna say hate in this house
if you say the word hate then you're
choosing to fill in the blank
consequence and i hate that i don't oh
actually i just said hate um i don't
like that um i don't want you to choose
those things because i want you with us
and i want you fully involved right um
but those those annoying things we're
not going to say bad words in the house
um that's just not how we talk to one
another here we treat each other with
dignity respect you can be sad and
frustrated all you want that's great um
but you're not gonna use ugly words uh
you're not gonna say bad words in the
house and and so on and so forth right
all that to say is
it's a mess
growing up and dating and
making
you know secondary families and kids the
whole thing's a mess
retain that ownership of that home and
let your daughter know i see you and i
hear you and you are allowed to have
your feelings
they're okay